which of the following graphs represents
the solutions to the system of equations
X is equal to two minus y and y is equal
to x squared minus four so essentially
we want to find the graphs that
represent these two equations and where
they intersect represent the solutions
so let's see y equals x squared minus
four that's going to be an
upward-opening parabola with the y
intercept of negative four and we see
that that is the case where I should say
the y coordinate of its vertex would be
negative four right over there and also
the y intercept so that looks like this
one right over here and this is the only
one that opens like that so we can
immediately say that this is probably
going to be the red one
right over here but we can verify that
this line right over here is two minus X
so if I if I were to write this in
traditional slope intercept form I could
rewrite this as let's see X is equal to
2 minus y add Y to both sides we have y
plus X is equal to 2 or Y is equal to
negative x plus 2 so we see the y
intercept is 2 and its slope is negative
1 so that's indeed this line and so the
solutions here are going to be that
point and that point right over here red
is what represents the solutions to this
nonlinear system of equations